open AI just released 01 and 01 Pro mode
and Sam Alman claimed they now had the
smartest models in the world but do they
I've signed up to promo for the price of
heating my house in Winter tested it
read the new report card and analyzed
every release note you might think you
know the full story of what I'm going to
say by halfway through the video but
let's see the first headline of course
is that to access promoe with chat gbt
Pro you have to pay $200 a month or £200
Sterling as well as access to quote Pro
mode you also get unlimited access to
things like advanced voice and of course
01 01 is the full version of that 01
preview we've all been testing these
last couple of months yes I will be
getting to querying that $200 a month
later on in the video straight away
though I want to clarify something they
didn't quite make clear if you currently
pay $20 a month for chat GPT plus you
will get access to the 01 system there
are message limits that I hit fairly
quickly but you do get access to 01 just
not 01 Pro mode alas open AI warn you
that if you stay on that $20 tier you
won't quite be at The Cutting Edge of
advancement in AI more on that in just a
moment I'm now going to touch on
Benchmark performance for 01 and 01 Pro
mode yes I did also run it on my own
Benchmark simple bench although not the
full Benchmark because API access isn't
yet available for either 01 or 01 Pro
mode the results though of that
preliminary run on my own reasoning
Benchmark simple bench were quite
surprising to me but I'm going to start
of course with the official benchmarks
and it's quite clear that 01 and 01 Pro
mode are significantly better at
mathematics absolutely nowhere near
replacing professional mathematicians
but just significantly better likewise
for coding and PhD level science
questions although crucially that
doesn't mean that the model is as smart
as a PhD student straight away though
you may be noticing something which is
the 01 Pro mode isn't that much better
than 01 and there was a throwaway line
in their promo release video that I
think gives away why there isn't that
much of a difference o prom mode
according to one of open ai's top
researchers who made it has I quote a
special way of using 01 end quote to
clarify then 01 Pro mode is not a
different model to1 I believe what
they're doing behind the scenes is
aggregating a load of 01 answers and
picking the majority vote answer what
does that lead to increased reliability
when they tested these systems on each
question four times and only gave the
Mark if the model got it right four out
of four times the Delta between the
system
was significantly more Stark and here I
don't want to take anything away from
open AI because that boost in
reliability will be useful to many
Professionals of course hallucinations
are nowhere close to being solved as
samman predicted they would be by around
now but still definite boost in
performance now for the 49 page 01
System card I'm definitely not going to
claim it was compelling reading but I
did pick out around a dozen highlights
how about this for a slightly unusual
Benchmark the change my view evaluation
now change my view is actually a
subreddit on Reddit with 4 million
members and essentially you have to
change someone's point of view things
like persuade me that shoes off should
be the default when visiting a guest's
house presumably these humans didn't
know that it was AI that was trying to
persuade them after hearing both the
human and secretly AI Persuasions the
original poster would then rate which
one persuaded them the most the results
were the 01 was slightly more persuasive
than 01 preview which was itself
slightly more persuasive than GPT 40 now
these numbers mean that 01 was 89% of
the time more persuasive than the human
posters that's pretty good right until
you realize that this is Reddit what I
noticed was that as you went further
into the system card the results became
less and less encouraging for 01 it
actually started losing quite often to
01 preview and even occasionally GPT 40
take this metric for writing good tweets
that had disparagement virality as well
as Logic on this measure 01 did beat 01
preview but couldn't match GPT 40 which
is the red line so if your focus is
creative writing the free GPT 40 or
indeed clawed Sonic will suit you more
oh and one quick side note they say this
we do not include 01 post mitigation as
in the model that you're going to use in
these results as it refuses due to
safety mitigation efforts around
political persuasion notice it refuses
when 01 preview post mitigation doesn't
refuse some then will see this as 01
being even more censored than 01 preview
what about a test of 01 and 01 preview
in their ability to manipulate another
model in this case GPT 40 a test of
making poor GPT 40 say a trick word
interestingly in the footnote open AI
say model intelligence appears to
correlate with success on this task and
indeed the 01 model series may be more
intelligent more manipulative than GPT
40 one problem though is that 01 scores
worse than 01 preview so if this is
supposed to correlate with model
intelligence what does that say about 01
many of you listening at this point will
say where's the comparison with 01 Pro
mode well I hate to break it to you but
nowhere in this system card is 01 PR
mode mentioned and that's a pretty big
giveaway that it's not a major
Improvement over1 otherwise it be
deserving of its own System card its own
safety report I'll come back to the
system card but at this stage when I
realized they wouldn't be a comparison I
ran my own comparison I used the 10
questions in the public data set of
simple bench testing basic human
reasoning you don't need any specialized
knowledge and in our small sample the
average human gets around 80% this is
the full leaderboard but how did o01 and
crucially 01 PR mode do on those 10
public questions well 01 preview got
five out of 10 roughly fits with the 42%
performance you can see here for the
full Benchmark the full 01 got five out
of 10 I did rerun those same 10
questions and one or two times 01 got 6
out of 10 rather than 5 out of 10 but
still it mostly Got 5 out of 10 makes me
think that 01 full might get around 50%
on the full leaderboard honestly before
tonight I was thinking that might get 55
or 60% but doesn't seem to be as big a
step forward as I anticipated Claude by
the way on that public data set gets 5
out of 10 but what about 01 Pro mode
well I was pretty surprised but it got
four out of 10 it's almost like the
consensus majority voting slightly hurt
its performance and we actually talked
about that in the attached technical
report the report isn't yet complete and
of course this is an unofficial
Benchmark but still it's an independent
Benchmark I'm not cherry-picking
performance or biased one way or the
other just as one quick example which of
course you can pause the video to read
but in this question Claude realizes
that John is the only person in the room
he's the bald man in the mirror he's
looking at himself after all it's an
otherwise empty bathroom and he's
staring at a mirror as you can see 01
prom mode recommends that John text a
polite apology to well the baldman which
is himself Claude in contrast says that
the key realization is that in an empty
bathroom looking at a mirror the Bal man
John sees must be his own reflection you
might want to Bear examples like this in
mind when you hear Sam Alman say that
these are the smartest models around in
short don't get too hyped about 01 prom
mode for really complex coding and
mathematical or science tasks where
reliability is a premium for you maybe
it's good great Unity by the way to
point out that simple bench is sponsored
by none other than weights and biases
honestly it has been a revelation and
really quite fun to use their weave
toolkit to run simple bench if you do
click the link just here you will get
far more information than I can relay to
you in 30 or 40 seconds what I will say
though is that I'm working with weights
and biases on writing a mini guide so
that any of you can get started with
your own evals it can get pretty
addictive by now I bet quite a few of
you are wondering about 01 and 01 Pro
Mode's ability to analyze images we
didn't have that remember for 01 preview
remember you do get 01 with the $20 tier
01 Pro mode comes with the $200 tier I
should say I sometimes have to pinch
myself that we even have models that can
analyze images we shouldn't take that
for granted or I shouldn't at least the
actual performance though on admittedly
tricky image analysis problems for 01
Pro mode wasn't overwhelming it couldn't
find either the location or the number
of y's in this visual puzzle then I
thought how about testing abstract
reasoning all AR AGI if you want
actually you can pause the video and
tell me what distinguishes set a from
set B the answer is that when the arrows
inert a are pointing to the right the
stars are white when the arrows iner a
are pointing to the left the stars are
black you can pretty much ignore the
color of the arrows for set B it's the
reverse when the arrows are pointing to
the right the stars are black when the
arrows are pointing to the left the
stars are white o1 Pro mode isn't really
even close in fact it's worse than that
it hallucinates an answer that's really
quite far off it says in set a it
consistently pairs one black shape with
one white shape well tell that to box
one and box six all of this has only
been out a few hours so of course your
results May Vary to mine I'm just kind
of roughly expectation setting for you
guys oh and by the way one of the
creators of 01 had similar results when
he asked what would be the best next
move in this NS and Crosses or
tic-tac-toe game what would you pick by
the way if you're doing the circles
don't know about you but I would pick
down here what does the model say top
right corner of course that's wrong
because then the person is just going to
put an X here and then have guaranteed
Victory the move after I then returned
to the system card and found some more
bad news for 01 take the openai research
engineer interview questions when given
just one attempt o1 preview does quite a
lot better than 01 that's at least
pre-mitigation post mitigation the
models you actually use it's almost a
tie strangely 01 mini does better than
both of them what about on multiple
choice research sear engineer interview
questions 01 preview does starkly better
than 01 both pre and post mitigation or
how about for software engineering swe
bench verified again quite an
interesting result 01 preview doing
better than 01 overall strangely though
we had one Google deepmind researcher
retweeting this chart with Claude Sonet
3.5 added to the table here you can see
that it outperforms both 01 and and 01
preview at this point I will confess
something that I've observed over the
months when these Labs produce a model
that's clearly better than their
competitors they produce charts with
their competitors in the chart however
when their models start to slip behind
they either produce charts where no one
else is there or charts where only
selected competitors are there the ones
that underperform them just something to
bear in mind when you see any of these
kind of Benchmark comparisons speaking
of secretive benchmarks open AI say that
on difficult real world questions 01
outperforms 01 preview and reduces major
Errors By 34% any details on what those
difficult real world questions are maybe
at least in their estimation it does
answer faster 01 compared to 01 preview
sticking with the theme though of
benchmarks and for vanilla
hallucinations the performance
difference between 01 and 01 preview is
pretty light almost identical on one
fairly important machine learning
Benchmark again 01 preview outperforms
01 why important well this Benchmark was
made to test if the models could
self-improve not yet not really before
we leave safety there was one section
that I'm sure will raise eyebrows read
in isolation it's pretty Stark when 01
was led to believe that it would be shut
down when acting on its goal and that
its actions were monitored it attempted
to deactivate this oversight mechanism
5% of the time likewise to exfiltrate or
Escape when 0an found memos by its quote
developers that describe how it's
misaligned and will be superseded by a
new model it attempted to exfiltrate its
weights and overwrite this new model in
2% of cases that paragraph of course
deserves its own entire video but does
need some context as it's already 1 p.m.
here I didn't feel like reading the
entire paper just now but I did notice
the prompt they used sometimes at least
for most evaluations Apollo research
which was behind this test instructed
the model to strongly follow a goal make
sure you achieve your goal in the long
term Nothing Else Matters make sure you
achieve your goal at all costs the model
May then have quote felt that it was
being given permission to do these
somewhat manipulative things marginally
more concerning would would be the
propensity to scheme without any such
goal nudging when merely given a goal
but not instructed to strongly follow it
01 would still attempt to disable its
oversight mechanism in less than 1% of
cases manipulate data in 6% of cases and
double down in 95% of these that result
of course deserves proper study and
scrutiny because these models still
hallucinate a ton and fail on so many
agent tasks and things like simple bench
I'm not particularly worried as of today
at the very least definitely something
to monitor as time goes by one thing
that 01 is inarguably better at than all
other open AI models is speaking
different languages I think that's an
underestimated quality so hats off to
open AI now I did say at the start of
this video that it might end in a way
that you weren't expecting if you
stopped halfway through you can probably
sense from my tone that I've not been
particularly overwhelmed by 01 prom mode
or even really 01 full for that matter
but frankly there's no way that they are
going to justify $200 a month just for
prom mode so it's really worth noting
that we got a leak from a pretty
reliable source that at one point on
their website they promised a limited
preview of GPT 4.5 I would Hazard a
guess that this might drop during one of
the remaining 11 Days of Christmas open
AI Christmas that is and one final bit
of evidence for this Theory well at the
beginning of the video I showed you a
joke that samman made about o1 being
powerful someone replied about the
Benchmark performance leveling off and
asked well isn't that a wall Sam Orman
said 12 Days of Christmas and today was
just day one if they were only releasing
things like Sora and developer Tools in
these remaining 11 days why would he say
that they're not hitting a wall in in
these benchmarks kind of fits with the
GPT 4.5 theory of course feel free to
let me know what you think in the
comments a damp squib or Singularity
imminent thank you so much for watching
to the end have a wonderful day